importante domingo electoral para tres
países de américa latina perú se estaría
enfrentando a las elecciones más
fraccionadas de su historia tras la
convulsa destitución de martín vizcarra
al que siguieron tres presidentes en
sólo una semana los últimos sondeos
auguran un empate técnico entre cinco
candidatos si bien ninguno alcanzaría el
15%
yonhy lescano keiko fujimori verónica
mendoza el economista hernando de soto y
el ex portero george forsyth son los
principales beneficiarios en las
encuestas pero aproximadamente el 30 por
ciento de los electores no tiene claro
por qué en votar la gestión de la
pandemia centrado el debate electoral y
desde ya se pronostica una segunda
vuelta ecuador ya llegó a esa segunda
vuelta para elegir a su nuevo presidente
tras el polémico recuento de la primera
vuelta que dejó fuera el candidato
indígena ya q pérez los ecuatorianos
deberán elegir entre el candidato
correísta andrés allowed y el
centroderechista guillermo lasso la duda
ahora radica en la dirección que tomará
el voto indígena dividido entre la
opción abstencionista y el apoyo a
andrés a la vez la jornada se completará
con la segunda
vuelta de las elecciones regionales en
cuatro departamentos bolivianos la paz
chuquisaca pando y tarija
el oficialismo teme que el más pierda la
gobernación de la paz que podría pasar a
manos de jala ya el partido de la
expresidenta y es integrante del + eba
copa alcaldesa electa del alto
entretanto chile debía celebrar comicios
este fin de semana para elegir los
constituyentes que redactarán la nueva
constitución pero el senado finalmente
aprobó su aplazamiento para el 15 y 16
de mayo por el preocupante aumento de
contagios de kobe 19 en el país